so I just didn't think that it was like
I thought it was I thought about it a
lot like a surgery you know like there
was something there that that uh that I
remember I was with animal years I had
just started when I was writing that
record I just started running and and I
was I was running and running I was back
in Idaho and I would go on these runs
down these kind of long gravel roads and
I remember sometimes just getting so
angry about nothing good specific it was
just just free-floating anger and I felt
like it was growing you know in me and I
I felt like like animal years was about
kind of just cutting that out and
getting it out you know and then once
that that was out I felt like I felt
pretty expunged and purged of it you
know so I didn't think that was I didn't
think that that was a it wasn't like I
was trying to go out there and teach
anybody a lesson you know I wanted to
kind of go out and say what I felt was
which I felt in animal years is about
kind of religion and whatever a religion
is getting taken away from people and
and used for kind of cynical ends and I
thought that uh but after that I had no
I had no desire to tell the people what
you know what to think
that's one of my that's one of my big
pet peeves like political most political
songwriting I'd say is just about you
know it's like teaching teaching people
like they're thinking like their
children or like they have never had no
experience with the world on their own
you know people believe what they
believe for a reason and and and I just
think music is the wrong place to try
and teach somebody you know especially
because I don't like I don't like
artists who are you know you know you're
a musician you're not a political
scientist or you know so so that and
then so going from that to conquest just
felt like it wasn't so much that I I
wanted to I wanted to stop writing
politically I just didn't I just didn't
feel the the drive to do that at that
time you know and it was just really fun
like conquest was a lot about you know I
was working with Sandra Stier my piano
player and he's my producer for this
this record as well and it was like just
experiment and it turned into this great
fun game you know recording which was a
whole new discovery you know getting to
work with somebody who really got what I
wanted
I think in a lot of ways in a lot of
ways this is a really defining record
for me making it I guess the major one
is the fact that they like you know I'm
I turned 33 and I have six records out
you know and at the end of my last
record I thought what am really I was
touring a lot and touring and touring
and I had you know just the chance to do
a lot of stuff and and and you know kind
of in the back of my mind while I was
doing it I was thinking what what's
gonna happen now you know what am I
gonna write about you know how am I
gonna keep from from you know being just
you know how am I gonna how am I gonna
keep this new how am I gonna keep making
new music and I was worried about it and
was just you know and and I wrote and
wrote and nothing seemed right you know
it felt like just felt like I was
repeating myself as like the Springsteen
song it's like you know you know same
old story same old act and I just you
know I just you know I always felt like
I I thought to get a career where I
could play music and write do that for
the rest of my life and I felt like when
I got to that point I suddenly felt like
do I have anything else to say you know
it's sort of like you know you're
campaigning for an office and once you
get there you have no idea what to do
you know I think that's it's dangerous
and I feel like I've met people who have
decided that that they've got to that
point and then they're just gonna
they're just gonna play their songs that
people know their hits and that's it and
they stop developing you know and I
didn't want that to happen so so I spent
a lot of time just kind of chewing on my
fingers and then trying to make sure
that like I could I could write some
songs that actually meant something new
one and that's that's out of that came
eventually out of a lot of working and
it's kind of strife life strife i-i-i i
started working on some songs one of
which was called the curse and it
started
as as just the idea of a mummy of a
mummys curse and that you know what
would happen if the mummy in the
archeologist fell in love and it was
like it was
you only need one song usually to get
you going you know one song to make you
feel like you can do this again you know
and that you're not as bad as you think
you are at the moment you know and once
that happens it's the world kind of
opens up